each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it is my pleasure to have Maziar
goudarzi with us today Missouri received
his PhD degree in 2005 from the sheriff
University in Iran and since 2006 he has
been a guest associate professor at the
University in Japan and today he will
talk to us about his work on software
and architecture techniques for cash
leakage reduction in nanometer scale
embedded systems thank you thank you
good morning thank you very much yes
today it's a great pleasure being here
with you this flagship research
institute of Microsoft and this
beautiful place my talk today is
regarding power consumption and reducing
power consumption some techniques for
poverty reduction well if you ask a
hardware design engineer or hardware
specialist regarding techniques to
reduce power he or she can tell you lots
of different kinds of techniques tens of
hundreds and each of them would be
perhaps useful for or customer
customized to one part of the system but
what we particularly are interested in
or software techniques for doing this
and the smart thing is that you could
you can do with your software so that
total power consumption would be reduced
just imagine it would it be would it not
be very interesting or excellent if you
could connect your mp3 player to your
computer and just upload a new version
of software to that and after that it
would play a while it would have played
ten hours of music for you now it plays
20 hours we did not degrade or or you
could do the same with your mobile phone
this is actually what we strive to
achieve doing some small things in
software so that without big changes in
your heart where you could achieve some
power
let me first start by the framework in
which we work this is a national project
crest under skin Christine Japan it is
consist it it is composed of four big
parts and we are one of those parts and
all parties we are in Kyushu University
nagoya university is the other
university involved and Petrucio boys
for evaluation the main target in this
project is reducing total power
consumption of processor-based embedded
systems by two orders of magnitude the
project is going to run for five years
and it started in 2006 well one big view
behind this is that we target embedded
systems embedded systems you know to
deserve anything like mobile phones
lengthy three players and there are a
big reasons why we are targeting
embedded systems if you take a look at
the history while personal computers is
started in grabs 1980 1981 and in 2008
it is estimated that total number of
personal computers would get to 1
billion and it is also anticipated that
divided 2015 it would get to 2 billion
so it took around 27 28 years for the
first billion and around seven years for
the next billion but the first mobile
phone was introduced in 1991 in Finland
and in 2006 there were 2.5 billion
subscribers to mobile service you see
that for the first billion of mobile
systems it took around 12 years and for
the second billion took only 30 months
and in 2008 at the beginning of 2008 4.3
billion cellular phones have been
manufacture and only in 2007 1 billion
has been manufactured you see that the
knob
is going very high very quickly reaching
very high numbers so that's one reason
behind the auto targeting and the
project are getting admitted system but
it does not mean that the techniques
that we provide do not work for
high-performance computers power is also
although power is male is very important
in embedded system because you have a
battery and you want to use it as long
as possible but in high performance
computing is also very important even at
the moment one point five percent of
total electricity produced in United
States is using data centers and in five
years it's expected to reach four point
five percent so reducing this total
power consumption or reducing the amount
of electricity bill that you pay would
be very important goal well let me first
give some very basic background and
power consumption I don't know whether
we are familiar with that or not but we
just a few points would be very helpful
when the dominant will technique to
technology for implementing chips
today's CMOS c-bus is basically things
like that as you see in each case only
one transistor is on each transistor can
be viewed as a simple switch you can
turn it on or turn it off for example
here this one is on because you have a
one here and this other one is off there
are three main mechanisms for power
consumption in CMOS technology the first
one is dynamic power this has
traditionally been the main source of
power consumption and it is all about
capacitors when when you have a wire you
you have some capacitor and when you
want to assert a one here you have to
give some electricity some electrical
charge inside this capacitance the
capacitance that would be here down to
here so that the value would be one at
that point and then when you want to
make it zero then you will you have to
discharge the capacitor and this is
power consumption this is called dynamic
power consumption the basic way to
reduce this kind of power is to reduce
the capacitor or the number of switching
that you do on that the second way is
short circuit power when you want to
switch this system for example from one
to zero in very short amount of time
both transistors would be conducting in
normal mode you see that only one of
them is on the other one is off so there
is no current actually between these two
but for a very short amount of time
there will be some high pairing between
these two but and to the technologies
this is negligible and the third one is
a static power or leakage this is the
big point this is becoming the main
source of power consumption in today's
systems actually what in the ideal case
you expect this transistor to be
corrected to be completely off to
conduct nothing but it does not does not
hold any more in to the technologies
with technology scaling there is a small
current going through this transistor
into the technologies and it is going to
be more I will show in a few seconds the
result of such a change so you do not
really like this the basic mechanism to
take to get rid of this leakage is to
turn off the circuit meaning that you
just do not let supply voltage be here
but you can only do this when the system
is not going to is not working it's not
doing anything useful and especially for
some for some things like cashman where
you cannot do that because you have some
values are some important values there
so we need to you need to do some some
other stuff all day for that the other
thing is for reducing the leakage power
is that you have some knobs there I will
talk about them vth and T or x these are
two knobs that will effectively control
the amount of leakage that you have in
this transistor but the disadvantage is
that they cost reduction of performance
of your system so you have to be careful
about that when thinking about
technology is scaling when we go to
lower technologies from say 90 nanometer
we go to 65 nanometer dynamic energy is
reduced since you are doing the smaller
things the capacitance is reduced and
also since everything is tinier you have
to reduce the power the power supply and
as you see here there is a quadratic
relation between a dynamic energy and
supply voltage and also capacitances
here so dynamic energy is effectively
reduced but the bad thing is that there
is this relation between delay and VDD
when you reduce VDD as I said in order
to keep the delay as before you have to
also reduce VT hv th's threshold voltage
this is one of those knobs that I said
this this can very effectively control
the leakage exponent it has exponential
relationship as you see here so static
energy has exponential relation to VT
edge so you reduce it the static energy
is increased very I the other knob is T
0 X gate oxide thickness again you can
reduce this and you have to do this
because you are scaling the technology
so in order to keep your transistor
world change you have to reduce the
oxide thickness when you also make the
transistor or smaller so as is you see
it's a kinetic energies increasing the
final result is that for a given
application say here mpeg2 process
application when going from different
from 180 nanometer technology down to 45
nanometer the total amount of the share
of leakage in total energy consumption
of system is increasing very highly as
you see here in 180 there is almost no
leakage a 90 nanometer it would be
something like this thirty percent or
something and it would quickly go to
fifty percent and higher actually this
is a pessimistic
in terms of off-chip memory did the bar
here you see here is of cheap memory
power consumption yeah grab is there
active power here as well for women
ships executing say no that's just
option memory and cache leakage energy
whatever yes yes they are also all in
this bar processor and off-chip memory
all of them the green bar is only for
data careful cash and the lower one is
for leakage and the point is that I said
that the share of leakage would be even
higher than this because we have assumed
that this part is the same for all
technology notes and that's not really
true it would be reduced this is leakage
power of cash for other parts of the GPS
you still have leakage but the main as i
will show you in a few seconds the main
consumer is cash so here it is only cash
and you can do much you can turn off
some parts of processor so that you
reduce leakage what's it with you why
why cash is the main reason I've in fact
about it just in a few seconds right
before getting to that I have another
bad news and that's it's the the leakage
is also exponentially dependent on
temperature so you have a higher
temperature you go to higher temperature
you have higher leakage and when going
to smaller technology nodes there since
the amount of leakage thing is
increasing so you also see higher
increase totally cacia
I can't remember what Kelvin mounts to
turn to but this is kelvin so this is
100 degrees yes this is 100 degrees
sorry about that I should have written
it well this is take a problem okay so
this is 100 degrees centigrade not
partly right all right okay so you see a
static power would be even increasing
with temperature the other bad news is
leakage variation these results you can
see lots of similar results from Intel
IBM there is a big difference in the
same for different chips in the same
frequency in terms of leakage in other
words maybe the mp3 player that you get
maybe the one that you get works for 20
hours and the one that I get may work
only for five year for five hours
because the leakage is very hot yes
where this brutal keys are on the right
away because of cost you you need to
sell anything you can otherwise Intel
would not do a scenario that you just a
big nerd not fully accurate right in the
sense that if we are both going to
something very clear and these parts
would be typically dimmed based on their
frequency Omega characteristics and that
would be a very narrow window
uncertainty
favorite frequency in particular part
that i get if you're getting an artist
lower power or higher for the same
finishing and you might be more but
there will be that uncertainty well the
quantum perhaps was at the end to what
you said about the cost well yes they do
frequency being so for example they be
in some of the chips around here in the
normalized follicular the frequency
these are these are not working as fast
as the other ones around here so they
would be much cheaper but how about
these ones all of them or all of these
chips around here have the same
frequency so ideally you would like to
sell them in this at the same price but
you cannot do that perhaps because the
because of the change that you see in in
terms of battery lifetime so again you
they need to perhaps do some being
around here or get rid of some of these
but it means that the loss of money
there are many things like that but
adaptive body biasing but all of them
have the difficulties associated with
them but adaptive body biasing is very
expensive to implement because you need
to a special manufacturing process and
I'm just saying marbleizing right well
you have to be adapted in that case
because different chips need different
biases we have an accurate information
about how many percent off the chips are
over 10 X in this case possible because
this truck is not that they formative at
all like 3x the shocking number but in
that Club in there are 1 medium points
and if there are like on the order of 30
points then it should be just a me I
don't have accurate results as you see
this is taken from Dec 2003 but Sonny
Nassif in asp deck 2008 showed a similar
thing again he's from our ib and I think
or maybe I apologize if I make a mistake
but the point is that it's not
negligible if it's where negligible they
should certainly they would certainly
make neglected okay the other point is
this is what i said i will talk about
the cash and why leakage is so important
in that as you see in most processors
whether it would be a high-performance
pro service such as alpha or embedded
power processor such as power pc or
strong are a large part of the chip is
going to consist of cash you see forty
percent 75% over fifty percent and as i
said you have valuable information in
the cash so you cannot turn it off
simply turn it off you would lose the
data and then it would result in high
performance degradation and the other
point is that most parts of cash are
often either you have lots of data there
you cannot ignore them but most of time
we are not accessing day this is the
problem and one other problem i will get
it get to it in a few slides is
variation since most of the chip is
consumed is consumed by cash transistors
you have to design the transistor with
the smallest size and the smaller the
size the higher the variation are we
shall show this in a few slides
the high variation means that again
leakages barrier changing very much they
will among different parts of the cash
so that's why we we have focused on
cache memories and while talking about
leakage reductions so today if I find
time I will talk about four techniques
for more of our more recent works the
first that first two ones are compiler
techniques particularly well actually
pure software techniques the third one
is an architecture one and the last one
is a combination of software
architecture oh yes yes indeed even you
it's it is although caches is still
taking care of the most mostly used data
but it's still only a small percentage
of those that data is used at any time
so most of data is not used yes indeed
just a tiny fraction of the cash most of
the time has been for example proposals
for cash decay so take in which you
basically make your division that is
this generator behavior in character
desperate if i calculate has not been
touched for a while you invalidate
that's right but you have some people
massive radiation but well they have
taken care of that and have shown that
that performance degradation is not very
high but the main problem is
implementation so far as I know there
are no or very few implementation real
implementation of that although cash PK
has been proved proposing 2002 right
that's the main problem okay so the
first technique is some variation of our
compiler techniques the basic point is
that i will show you that due to
variation within guy or intra dive
aeration the amount of leakage in SRAM
cell depends on the value that you store
there so if you take care of the value
storing it each SRAM cell you can reduce
total leakage this is the basic
mechanism as I said so I'm going to
lower technology knows the transistors
are no longer perfect the parameters
that you the parameters of the
transistor would change these changes
can be viewed over different chips on
the same wafer this is called joy to do
I variation and it can also be seen even
within the same guy so this is called
introd I've aeration both of these
variations have become very important
especially from 90 nanometer forward you
see lots of in strawberry ation and the
final result is that even adjacent
transistors with the same design size
have different parameter values the
parameter that is that I'm talking what
is V th remember that knob that I talked
about regarding leakage so to transistor
with the same size and even if they are
adjacent to each other have differently
th values this mainly comes from a
phenomenon called random dopant
fluctuations for the sake of time let me
just say that well in previous
technology nodes you would have a big
channel area a big transistor and lots
of at
thousands of atoms would go there these
atoms are dopant atoms that that they
basically control the features of the
transistor but when you go to a smaller
sizes you have just tens or hundreds of
these atoms so the statistical variation
of these numbers and the way that they
would be whether they are uniform or
non-uniform completely defines the
features of that transistor that's why
you see random variations and as I said
here you see that the variation is huge
in a small transistor and in cash
remember that you have very small
transistor because it is area constraint
so you see the worst case of variation
in cash some empirical results this one
comes from 130 nanometer shows thirteen
percent variation in current in leakage
current while 67 millivolt variation for
vth inside the same chip and you see
again the exponential variation is
exponential relation between vth and sub
threshold leakage so the final result is
that exponentially the leakage of two
transistors will be exponentially be
fine and in terms of a single aslam sell
the final result will be shown here this
is a single SRAM cell the this is
actually two cross-coupled not gates
this is one not this is the other one
and these are two transistors for
accessing this strand sir this is a
standard sixth transistor samsel if it
is storing a one here the other node
would be zero and these three
transistors shown here would contribute
to leakage in this case but if you
change the value the other transistors
would be contributing to leakage and as
I said the leakage of this transistor is
different so the final result is that
leaches when a story 0 is different from
the religious you and storing one this
is the basic point that you take
advantage of in our techniques
in order to find out how much difference
would be would result from this fact we
ran some a Monte Carlo simulations the
value of intra die we th variation the
values are taken from itrs roadmap ITRs
is international technology roadmap for
semiconductors this is actually the
organization that works as the reference
for the future estimations so in 2007
it's expected to have thirty three
percent you see it is very it is going
very quickly to 112 percent variation in
2018 well actually this shall not happen
because such a variation cannot be
really tolerated but anyway it is show
the trend and we measure the total
difference between full match of the
values to the preference of the SRAM
cells and fool mismatch and the final
result is the maximum leakage saving as
you see here so in 2012 with fifty eight
percent variation in VT edge you could
expect something around sixty percent
difference between full match and
fullness match is Jenny but it sounds
like you need an Oracle it tells you for
every memory cell whether it's cheaper
to store 0 or 1 there that is that right
you need to test it you need to do some
testing you need to store one in each
SRAM cell then store is 0 there in both
cases you need to measure the current
which is flowing to the chip so you find
out whether the data strategies and I'm
given sitting high memory reading one
fork a long memory or something it seems
like the leakage would be about the same
these variations you're going to be
random friendly attributed across all of
the individual cells well if you do not
take care of the values it would be
almost the same but if you sorry what is
how do you measure you can you measure
the difference yes d short one bit yeah
working with members of a point in the
paper we have shown the reference to
some japanese
measure point 1 M 2 ampere fem Harper is
if I'm not mrs. making steak 10 to the
minus 15th power so point 1 M 2 ampere
is very very accurate but well you do
not need to be dead accurate what you
want to measure is to measure hundreds
of non-lumpers because the leakage is
high the leakage in in a 90 nanometer
technology that we have the leakage of a
single transistor is around 1 number so
if you make if you can measure around
109 number that's fine because you do
not want to be just as accurate as one
na number you want to differentiate
between the cells that have the highest
difference between a storing is e1 a1 so
if there is a say 100x difference
between a storing zero and one that
that's it would be a good target for
doing value control it depends on how
you measure it if you measure it using
external equipment it would be I know
some references to two testers that do
it in 100 kilohertz so one hundred
thousand samples can be taken in one
second with the accuracy of 100 na na /
but what you want to do is the best way
to do that is to use things called pics
building current sensors you design some
space on a small circuit inside that can
measure the current for you that's the
way to do it certainly something I want
and much more accurate because you are
doing it inside the chip if you go
outside the chip you have what is the
radio game yeah with chicken if built in
with building I think yeah but it still
depends on the accuracy that you want to
get but you can go to for this for this
year you can get over one megahertz
easily go over Monica
testing the student will be done at this
time no no for every chip you can't you
have to do it memorizes post very
nurturing before you ship the part yes
if you do the built-in current sensor
you had better do it measure it in field
so that for example when you buy your
mobile phone you run a setup or
something like that the software goes
and measures these values and it stores
them somewhere to take care of that this
is the best way to do it yes but the the
main point is that they differ at the
relation between leech one and lick zero
meaning is still the same well yes
temperature goes high so lick one and
lick zero busco hi but if lick one is
higher than liquid zeroed it remains to
be hired a leak 0 never it doesn't
actually never time isn't it worse yes
it does Oh over climate if it gets worse
over what time period so if you do the
test is beginning and then a day later
or I think it's just not today but over
years it does Oh use a cell phone for me
sorry it's actually aging is becoming
the other problem it is one of the
problems that rely reliability people
are working on the power savings you're
going to get here compared to base power
of a problem with the screen United all
the other pieces that are on it I mean
what percentage of our savings do you
think this type of work live impact
well this well of course if you think
about a complete embedded system such as
a mobile phone the main part is LCD
panel so and the wireless yes certainly
but the point is that once as long as
you do not impact them it's good to save
power anywhere are you mean compared to
the total total power for I do not have
the complete value yeah precise sorry
Your Majesty sensors we're I don't have
an accurate results but i think the
power consumption of LCD would be at
least 5 times 5 damn processor but we
are mainly concerned in processor in the
project that I said Chris project in
Japan that three other groups one of
them works on wireless the other works
on optoelectronics I think there and
another one on LCD ok so finally we get
that some cells prefer zero meaning that
the leakage would be less when storing
zero some other prefer one so what we
want to do is to give every cell the
things that it prefers in data cache
maybe it's very hard to do because you
have basically random values but for
instruction cache you can do lots of
things at least we did these three the
first one is reordering instruction
within each basic block given a basic
block we reorder instructions inside
that so that the matching would be
improved we also change register
operands of instructions so that again
the matching between the instruction and
the corresponding cache cell would be
improved and the third technique says
that let's initialize the cash so since
some parts of the cash are not used by
the application that you are running we
suggest to initialize those parts to the
best value the best match for that cash
sorry well if you could you would
certainly do that but it's very
expensive to do that's what i said in
regarding cash DK yes if it is possible
it's better to turn them off well for
the sake of time let me keep these parts
you can talk about them well this is one
point this is important since we need to
take care of each chip differently each
chip has its own leakage profile so you
need to optimize for each chip
differently so the way to do that is to
the way that we propose to do that is to
get the application binary impede on for
the first time then get real-time
operating system do the optimization for
you change the application binary and
the restore it in the pier arm and
finally in the subsequent executions it
would be run without needing
optimization again in other words you
you you can get your mobile phone you
can run some optimizer on that and after
that the system works fine kind of
installation process say again let me
desert simple point zero one big one
important point is only that since we
are working on basic blocks we do not
change the address of basic block you do
not change the size of basic blocks so
the pit and Miss ratio of instruction
cache is the same as before just some
changes in data cache may happen but in
our experiments it was less than one
percent change this is important since
you can do instruction reordering in a
bigger visibility but it would impact
the instruction cache and this is the
register renaming technique we just
change the register operands this is
these are the instructions of m32 are
this is a embedded processor i guess
nobody has ever heard the m32 are no
this is some japanese this is very
popular in japan
these are the operands that you can
handle so some of the instructions can
be changed and this is some results from
running one application say here a 50
application this is on a two-way cash
this is 8 kilobyte cache and the results
show the vertical axis shows the number
of cash to field operations so in these
parts you have 0 actually feels meaning
that that's part of cash is never used
so you can initialize all of them this
is the algorithm let me again skip it
it's simply a list scheduling algorithm
we ran the algorithm of benchmarks from
my bench benchmark suit these are the
characteristics of the benchmarks and we
to take care of the variation we use
Monte Carlo simulation of 1000 chips and
these are the final results for each
application you see two bars here the
left hand side bar is divided two into
two parts this is the original totally
change some parts are consumed some
leakage corresponds to the used parts of
the cash the yellow one is unused parts
and the right hand bar for each
application shows they improved 10 this
is it is m32 our processor cache size is
eight kilobyte direct map cache 1000
caches and these are the average results
I've for each cache as I said each chip
is different from the other one in terms
of leakage profile so you have to do it
over 1000 and then average what any
specific points of
well the process and 32 are it is fixed
it is the RISC processer five pipe five
stage pipeline processor it is single
issue and running on 200 megahertz ok so
you up here as you see in case of for
example jpg the number of unused cash
cells is very low so you do not get as
much as the leakage reduction as you get
on if I are if I or is a very small
benchmark so you get lots of power
saving here using cash initialization
here you get the you see the average
saving results for technics one and two
this technique one was instruction your
scheduling to is register renaming
overall they get they give us around
twenty percent reduction alone on the
used parts of the cash and technique
three gives almost fifty five percent
reduction for the unused parts of the
cash so the total is here and the
maximum saving the cheap meaning the
chip that gives you the magnet the
maximum saving is shown here there is
just the fewest percentage of more
saving here that means of chips that
told you the very issues the witches as
you we just simulated using monte carlo
simulation the basic point the basic
parameter is the vth variation the
amount of vth variation which is usually
expressed in terms of percentage
percentage of three sigma over mu so
when it when you say ten percent is that
three sigma is ten percent of the mean
value we get this value we generate
different vth values we have the basic
leakage of an ideal transistor so we get
the leakage of each transistor in each
case it's problem
so what's out you're looking at proving
the linkage in the instruction cache but
Chris is the heat and the data you know
the data application did you do anything
to try to optimize leakage in that area
in the heap itself if it is implemented
while we are working on cash we are so
we did not work on off-chip memory the
oh you talking about data cache I said
data cache the value that we're having
data cache is basically random so we
have not done that but yes if you find
some some proposal to who take better
advantage of the take better control
over the value is stored in the data
cache yes it would be fine what we did
not do that you made some work is very
practical techniques that you could
actually implement with you know
hardware that we have today why being
them but there must be something hard
about it you haven't that I don't can't
see because you did it in simulation
instead of doing it real hardware so
what's hard about it that what why can't
it be done well we did simulation
because we did not have enough budget to
implement a real chip on that but for
practical implementation I think we need
we need to spend some time on the design
of the current sensor this is the main
point your knee it's research that you
know you don't we gonna ask well there
are lots of solutions for that because
there is a kind of special kind of
testing called I ddq and this is just
measuring currents so we can reuse them
but they are usually designed for higher
currents although they can be customized
for very small currents that we want so
that's the basic port
so going back to this possible
comparison to cash the case so what
can't you get people have reported if I
remember correctly in forex reduction in
cash in English our four min will
perform a saucepan what you're saying is
true that there's you know there's an
area penalty in tailoring so encounters
infinite but this technique is not free
either because you need these current
sensing potato chips so how would the
orbit compare if you do well at one
point is that in cash DK you do not just
need some contours some extra concert
the basic point is that you need to be
able to control each cache line
separately so you need to have some
controlled supply voltage line for each
cache line this is the main problem i
think not the counters the counters
would be would not be a big point and
that's why I think it's not it's not
been implemented but here you just need
some current sensor for the entire cache
so it is it is basically very small the
current sensor especially if you design
it inside the chip in mobile phones are
the cash-strapped man for this it
completely depends but the direct maps
are sometimes preferred because of power
efficiency in the set associative caches
you have much higher power consumption
but whether they are more effective in
terms of performance so some sometimes
well processors such as are they
sometimes even have 32 cash ways but
basically people prefer direct map cache
is in embedded systems another thing you
can do is you'd be trying to rest
crossref we will complete the weather
power I'm sorry I didn't complicated
compress the Kurds fix up less space
mm-hmm it's a lot of dependency
varieties right so you look at that in
terms of how much cash your being which
are the requirements of insurance what
compressing is one basic technique for
reducing the size required but it needs
dynamic power you need to spend some
dynamic powerful compressing and then
decompressing when needed well we
technology scaling since I said that
dynamic energy consumption is reducing
that maybe one basic point for going
toward that but we did not compare did
not compare our work to that one ok so
the breakdown of liquid savings
achievable here is well around ten
percent can be achieved with the
technique one and other turbines ten
percent with taking two and the rest
comes from cash initialization effect of
cache size was studied as you increase
the size of cash you as you decrease the
size of cash the amount of unused parts
of cash would be reduced so in the case
of mpeg-2 for example coming from 16
kilobyte to 4 kilobyte you say you see
that the all the cache lines are used so
the unused part is reduced but for small
cash for a small application such as if
I or this does not happen very much the
same holds for cash associated ET at
higher associated it is again you get
better usage of the available cash
capacity so in case of impact coming
from direct map to a to a cash again the
number of our new sketch becomes 0 so
you get basically only techniques 1 and
2 to reduce leakage but for FY are again
you see that not much difference happens
on the effectiveness of techniques one
and two
since in direct map cache you have
one-to-one relationship between each
instruction and the cache memory the
technique can be much more accurate but
in set associative caches you have 4n
way cash you have in different ways very
unrealistic you're basically looking for
computational kernel of an application
on my fam Cal device little screen we're
not going to want to run a campaign to
Qatar and not run the code actually
display the image on my screen so I'm
not going to be able to go and
initialize all the immunes cache
locations outside of anything to decoder
to some random value that minimizes
chest size because i'm going to have
code in those locations that are going
to be my system chrome like splinter or
whatever the UI close there as well so
here is actually going to work in a real
system as opposed to bench one here girl
ambulance systems it there are lots of
systems that you have to only one
application to run in that case the
application is more than a computational
colonel I mean there's no point running
them beg to differ you don't do
something with young well any
application that you have well you you
may say that will impact to is just the
colonel application but for any other
application you can run and if you find
no unused cash okay you can still use
techniques one and two and they give and
they give you around twenty percent
reduction in leakage that's why we have
analyzed the effect of different cache
sizes different associated et yes it
reduces the amount of leisure saving if
you do not have enough unused cache
lines but if you do have okay let's
reduce cash in that case
okay so techniques one and two have to
the technics wanna to have to know which
cache line has the highest probability
of the hosting the instruction since we
do provide this information to the
optimizer then the result is that for no
matter what what is the number of cache
ways available the performance of these
two techniques is almost the same it
really seems like a waste acitivity
because you're affecting your
effectively eight you don't know where
it's going to go you know for what an
eight chance so why doesn't it
dramatically drop off with the sister
Tiffany was but well in the simulations
in these simulations it it turns out
that only one of the one of the cache
ways have the highest probability of the
store of hosting that cache line that
that instruction but yes in in general
it may not completely hold in these
applications in these simulations this
did happen we run the simulation the
entire application and using
instructions that simulator and this
gave us the cash way with the highest
probability the longer yes you can get
the dirt the remaining we're not took
into account the way we should expect
the cash to be in cache line we're
expecting happen again yes wait that's
that's the information that comes from
instruction set simulation of the back
of the benchmark okay so regarding the
third technique for cash initialization
again you have to pay some dynamic
energy to execute some instructions to
initialize the cash so that you get some
Lykke saving so there should be some
breakeven points between these two and
we measured it using the typical energy
consumption of
structions in m32 are in our
implementation our typical
implementation was on point 18 micron so
these values are actually worst-case
breakeven points because if you are
talking about 90 nanometer then the
power consumption of m32 all processors
should also come from 90 nanometer what
these results are from point 18 but the
as you see in basically in most
applications is a fraction of a second
but for in the worst case for jpeg it is
around 3 seconds meaning that if your
application is going to or if your
embedded system is going to run for
three seconds or more in this case it is
ok to do caching visualization otherwise
it would not give you some liquor saving
this also could this also goes back to
the question over there that if you do
not have enough unused cache lines then
cash initialization would not be a good
choice okay with technology scaling with
technology scaling the amount of
variation as i said is going to go very
high over one hundred percent we analyze
this effect very different sigma v th
and as you see again the technology
scaling the amount of saving would
increase this isn't additional sorry
usually cash this relation at every
context wish what we assumed here was
only know we assume that once it is done
at boot time of the processor we assume
that this processor is going to run only
that application yes in that case you
had better and not necessarily at any
context switch I think that the best way
is to explore I think many ways can be
done you can do it every context which
you can do every time that you change
the application not necessarily at the
pre specified time slices
he asking it I'm having trouble finding
contacts network I feel like we're
certified layers deep and if you were to
break down energy use of the device then
I said the screen and a big wireless
transmitter and a bunch of chips ice and
one of those chips as but the processor
in cash and within that cash there's
some of the week since someone's dynamic
and you're good with in leakage you can
reduce that by thirty percent and if you
pop all way back onto the top level I
don't have an intuition you going to get
five percent 4.0 five percent total
power reduction for the devices on home
well as i said i do not have accurate
results to give you how much would be
the total power consumption they
embedded system because it completely
depends on what embedded systems you
have what what is the number of states
that you are talking about and what our
Disqus sorry i guess is giving an
intuition for me one too it's not done
exhausted since very application
sensitive and I sense an infant I guess
I just didn't kind of sense for it if it
would ever matter or if it matters we
ministered instead of application for
devices answered music-sharing imagery
what if I would buy a bed advice that
Jesus one wat face bar mm-hmm what
should I and this is could you do you
have any sense of the budget since you
seemed ever since the budgets for
different devices that they got anybody
device so we're hoping that then you
pick up some sense of what how the same
is going to impact the overall based on
race for the processor the m32 our
processor that we had in point 18
consumes 200 millivolts at 50 megahertz
right but oh why I said the that i do
not have actually accurate results
because i do not have the actual
resource of the power consumption LCD or
wireless parts that's what I asked you
for your name is you're not scoring
manage business over the mountain i
think for USA v %
I think it could be very well this say
if you if you get fifty percent here it
will be reduced to perhaps around ten
percent or five percent in the entire
system because of the total power
consumption of other parts but the point
is that in embedded system you do not
really talk about the entire world for
big picture that's fine but as long as
you do not impact the other part it is
fine to reduce on party you usually
focus on one part of the system you try
to optimize that part yes it is
certainly important to find out which
part is the best target so in verse that
part having unintended impact on the
other parts which causes based power
consumption grow up that's where I'm
sorry okay it is previous phone to the
future that's a voice recognition in
this room yes I thought he should be
very very sensitive to very accurate to
what kind of optimization you propose
you should show that the embedded system
computing it is very the people in the
conference's I mean are very sensitive
to what kind of impact you may have on
other parts there's this much variation
for the possibilities is that the
transistors feel tired hmm so if you
thought at all about using simple
technique I mean basically the fact that
you if you have these failed transistors
using an analysis like this actually
avoid you using them at all or using
them in a way that would make him not
work that's 11 actually concerned for
Islam designers yes they are very
concerned on the weather with these
variations that the final SRAM cell is
going to work or not and as you see here
these are the forecasts of our TRS they
say that is we would have won over one
hundred percent variation is in VT
edgewood this is certainly not a thing
that is going to happen because you have
such a thing that then that strands that
would
it's really work but what to have just
some forecasts or the trend on how much
leakage you can get we just use these
values yes reliability is very important
in some people even say that it's from
cells especially may not be shrunk
anymore but it is still to be seen okay
so algorithm execution time on the
processor is just a few seconds and
finally the summary of these parts who
have I not even come to the other parts
anyway this was a simple software
technique and one important point one I
think beauty of the technique is that
you do not we we address the parts of
the cash that are actively being used
this is important because usually as i
said the basic technique for leakage
reduction is to disable that parts that
are not being used but how about the
parts that are being used techniques one
and two that we propose can address
those parts this can be applied to a
scratchpad memory and also you can have
some more sophisticated optimizations or
value control on the cash okay this is
the second technique let me let me go
very much faster if we want to have the
four all right this is the static
register renaming again but this time
for a symmetrical stamps a somatic cell
caches these are some results from some
other researchers showing that the 01
contents of cash are biased towards 0 so
if you design the cat the SRAM cell such
that the leakage when storing is 0 is
much lower than you can save more energy
this is the basic mechanism that they do
for that as I said here for storing is 0
only these three transistors would
contribute to leakage so if you control
the knob and increase VTS you can save
energy they
proposed for designs and these are the
normalized leakages the first and second
color this is the normal cash and this
is designs 12 up to four these are the
four designs do the best for designs of
them and we basically do register
renaming again and basically you get
application source compile it you run
the static register renaming and store
the result in instruction memory if you
if your instruction cache is designed it
a symmetrical answers you get some
leakage saving this is the experiment
setup we avoided binary manipulation in
order to have to execute the simulations
done much faster so again these are the
benchmarks that we use and for different
designs you see differently shaped
savings or the best design where leakage
in case of 0 is 1 and leakage for 1 is
14 you get around thirty percent
reduction and for the other two with 40
to 50 and 42-14 243 you get around these
values but in this case we're wicked 0
and leakage one are almost the same the
leakage saving is not very high for the
designs with the oscillation turn are in
turn on yes yeah further differences of
hardness between the designs between the
leakage of the the register or plant
beets in the cache for two cases one
with the regular case this is the base
cash the other with the optimized cash
design sorry sorry the deferred the base
cash is not the regular one the base
cash is designed one for example in this
case without optimization then compared
to the same design but with optimization
when ice in this 30 perception i think
that that's really good and I want
design one or is it possible to design
for it's actually much better because
are you think she designed for install
here it is clear I think because the
leakage 0i leakage one are much lower
than this so in terms of leachate saving
it is higher than this and also in terms
of absolutely cage it will it is much
lower than this but in these two cases
you are right that the absolute value
should also be taken care of because
leakage is zero and leakage one are
almost the same in this case so although
the saving is also the same comparison
of these two I would be a little bit
more sophisticated I have results but in
a different slide so when it was in
other words just design something
remotely games even if it has no
opportunity for opposition sorry I don't
I didn't come back I then you could game
for DS 0 0 & 1 equals 1 hmm i don't
think so because if you could do that
you would certainly do that to reduce
total leakage previous slide he had he
had what this impacts in terms of delay
is set to move both of these to bury
them circle so presumably we have some
kind of trade-off not never seen yeah
maybe maybe it helps here you have some
trade-off yes you reduce the case 0 and
leakage one here but you also have their
to delay so the speed of the SRAM cell
is also getting impacted or changed at
least here yes you you give five percent
delay and these two are also some
parameter of reliability of the system
so there is a trade-off
but basically it's not it's not possible
to design it another stem cell to have
post League 0 and lick one to be one
okay four different cache sizes and the
cash associated et the result is the
same and this second technique is
simpler to finish this is software
technique as you see up to thirty three
percent which is saving the other
technically I think this takes too much
time if we want to finish so let me skip
this still let me just give you the
basic mechanism the point here is that
you have delay variation so different
the stem cells in the design have
different delays what we want to do is
to again use that knob we change VT edge
so that the leakage would be
exponentially reduced but this results
in a shift in the delay of the entire
system so some of these SRAM cells now
would be outside the target delay of us
right how do we take care of them we
propose to have additional cache lines
additional cash ways in other words you
have at the at the beginning you have
let me show this slide at the beginning
you have a four-way cash here then you
increase vth from say 272 3320 and some
of the cache lines now get become delay
violating how do you take care of them
you add an additional cash way here but
since they're increasing vth results in
exponentially the reduction of leakage
the linear increase of number of SRAM
cells in terms of additional cash way
would still benefit in the final system
in terms of showing that in a figure it
can be viewed like this this is the some
delay distribution we change the return
the knob so the ladies
tribution moves like this so some
additional stranzl delay while eating
strong stars happen here and we take
care of this number assuming that this
leakage distribution this delay
distribution follows Gaussian
distribution we have some analytical for
analytic formula so that the number of
these delay violating is from cells and
cache lines would remain such that the
total cache capacity remains the same so
this is the basic mechanism that we use
to get some liquid saving depending on
the amount of delay variation which has
been shown to be around three percent in
90 nanometer technology you can get some
Lykke saving as shown here with one
additional cash way you can get these
values and the second one the green one
shows world for two additional cash
weights but if you have five percent
delay variation you can get more leakage
saving even in case of two additional
cash ways and the results finally on
instruction cache would be like this
uncompressed benchmark with additional
with one additional cash where you can
get around twenty two percent but the
second extra cash rate does not help you
as much as before so cliche saving is
almost the same as this case so the
twenty-five percent additional area
would not be worse for unified cache for
l2 unified cache it would even better
serve you because in l2 cache the amount
of leakage is higher the share of
leakage to dynamic power is much higher
in this case but in data cache it does
not help you as much as before the main
reason is that in an instruction cache
you have the sequentiality point the
basic power consumption mechanism in set
associative caches
is due to tag comparisons so in a 4-4
very cash you have to do for
comparison's / access but in instruction
cache you do not really need to do that
because most of the time the next
instruction is in the same cache line
that you accessed before so in that case
you can escape tak comparisons if you do
that you could get the results that I
showed you here but in install but in
data cache you cannot do this for every
cache access you have to compare all the
four or five cash tags and yeah next way
means you have less cash so so your
performance is going to be reduced by
Thank You Wes can we do not have less
cash we have the same cache size or even
more because you see here for four we do
it such that just as before for every
catch this extra long pause okay if you
want to keep the area the same as before
you know it would not help but we assume
that we pay the extra area in other
words the cost of doing this thing is
the additional area that you you have to
have in the cap in the doctors next area
to gives you more cash that's make
arrangements run faster yes but how
about power the power would be also
increase because you have a larger cache
you also and you have the same vth as
before but in this case we have yes we
have larger cache but we have changed
the knob we have turned the knob so that
the leakage is reduced faster well you
get our you run faster but but the
leakage is 25 in this case for example
if you have full ray cash
the leakage would be also twenty-five
percent more in that case because you
have twenty-five percent more stem cells
right the total total energy consumption
you mean may remain that's right ok so
this technique gives you these savings
and okay let me get to the final one
temperature at a configurable cash the
basic valid points behind this is that
leakage depends on temperature so so if
you can configure your cash the
depending on the actual temperature of
the chip you can save lots of energy
I've shown already that dynamic energy
is reducing with technology and static
energy is increasing and also dependence
of leakage at two temperature so for
here in case of quicksort with reduction
in cache size you get a much higher
number of cycles for executing the cash
for exactly the application so dynamic
energy is increased with reduction of
cache size but before the same reduction
of life size the leakage energy is
reduced because you have a smaller cash
so the total would be the total result
would be that for different temperatures
you have different optimum points so you
had better optimize the cash for the
given temperature in which the system is
working in other words just just to give
some
ah some view it means that if you get
your mobile phone to our inside the car
park in in hot environment in sun
shining in summer the mobile phone may
not work as long as it would do in a
cold winter because of leakage so this
is the basic change that we want to have
in the car in the cache architecture we
want to have only configuration
controller here so that the
configuration of the cash can be
controlled under control of software and
software takes care of reading out the
temperature at design at at runtime and
configure the cash and finally it gives
you something around depending on the
temperature that you use and whether you
work on instruction cache or data cache
some savings as you see here will time
is really up so if you are interested
please come on let's talk about it more
so at the end I would say that the basic
message that we want to do is we want to
transfer is that what we have done and
we intend to continue is that we take
care of the technology trend in very low
levels in electrical engineering and the
electronics down there and we try to
find out some effects that can be
utilized at software level and system
level so that total power consumption
can be controlled in future the three
ways that we want to intern at at the
moment at least two more to do more
investigation is on real-time operating
systems is the first one because RTOS is
becoming much more popular in almost all
embedded systems it is already quite
popular in
mobile phones chip multiprocessors and
multiprocessor system and chips are also
becoming much popular and this is one
other area of future work and
reconfiguring system-on-chips and I had
to jump this some slided it's not in
this one the amount of the money that
you have to pay today for manufacturing
it chip is becoming multi-millions so
designing one chip their application is
no longer cost-effective so you have to
design it achieve that can be using
several different applications and one
of the ways to do that is reconfigured
system and chips when you have some
processor inside the chip and some of
PGA blocks around that there are lots of
such products already available from
xilinx al-quran all the ref PGA products
this is the other final point that we
are going to extend our research to I
have some other presentation on other
works in Kyushu University and also my
PhD work at sure if University but if
you anybody would be interested that
would be very happy to talk and discuss
it more thank you very much question